all successful products and companies
have one thing in common
insane growth and it starts with
increasing the adoption of the company's
products once the product launches into
the market it needs a champion to
optimize its business impact on
customers and influence in the
marketplace with the new growth product
manager nanodegree program from udacity
you can be that champion you'll learn
the experimentation and data driven
decision making skills necessary to
power your products to the next level of
scale
impact and profitability growth product
managers need a deep flexible and
comprehensive analytical skill sets that
covers the entire funnel
from customer acquisition to
monetization the growth product manager
nanodegree program from udacity gives
you that adaptability mindset and metric
based decision making dexterity that we
need whether you're already in a growth
focused role want to get into the growth
domain or want to learn how to expand a
product's customer base
then the growth product manager
nanodegree program from udacity is for
you at udacity you're topped by the best
so you can power insane growth and
propel the great products of the future
enroll in udacity's new growth product
manager nanodegree program today